[music playing]
NARRATOR: September,
1944, south-east of Japan,
USS Finback steams
toward the crash
site of an American plane.
10 miles away, a young pilot
drifts towards the shores
of a Japanese island
from which enemy
ships set out towards him.
[music playing]
The situation appears hopeless.
Until two American planes from
his squadron appear overhead.
[music playing]
[shooting]
The Avenger aircraft strafed
the Japanese vessels.
[shooting]
And they retreat to the
protection of the shore.
But now low on fuel,
the American planes
must return to their carrier.
[music playing]
The Aviator is vulnerable
and alone again.
[music playing]
To the south, USS
Finback approaches
the coordinates of
the downed airmen,
guided in by its air cover.
[music playing]
LOOKOUT: Life raft,
off the starboard bow.
NARRATOR: At last, a lookout
spots a bright yellow object
in the vast Pacific.
[music playing]
From the life raft after
more than three hours of fear
and struggle, the
20-year-old pilot
believes he has started to
hallucinate as he sees what
he describes as an apparition.
First a dark spot, then
a submarine emerges.
He worries that
might be Japanese.
[music playing]
But he identifies the
men on board with relief.
They are American.
[music playing]
USS Finback's photographic
officer rolls his camera.
Five submariners gather at
Finback's bow to recover
the bobbing life raft.
[music playing]
Just before noon, more than
three hours after the crash,
they pulled the
young pilot aboard.
[music playing]
He is safe.